yeah drink that coffee dream back
coughing them big old lips rat them lips
around that that black rifle mug mmm
made for sucking turkey yeah took it
took it took he doesn't chew it he sucks
it down till it all collapses let the
skin off a turkey now mm-hmm I take the
skin off a chicken sir do you I'll suck
a bird's beat are you excited for
Thanksgiving tomorrow
can't wait actually love all the kitties
around yeah I love the running around
cuz my football on yeah my my nieces and
nephews are there and they're so cute
dude I saw your nephews or just one
right or were they both there
that's a dumb store those were my
nephews yeah those are you nephew both
um were they're both people Jake and the
big boy I didn't see you boy I saw Jake
slow down the bathroom I just saw him
he's like what's up man dude he's
getting big oh dude
d1 but one of the best soccer players in
the country 100% great going well he's
gone he got into Williams which is in
academically it's the hardest school to
go yeah 54% of a graduating class of the
entering class for valedictorians and
when my my nephew my other nephew went
now he's going he's got great grades but
he's such a good soccer player that they
were just like so his choice was should
I go d1 or should I go like go to North
enums are an amazing academic school and
obviously choose academics yeah Ryan you
could do both but yeah I would too I
would hunt and his dad he's one of
smartest people we know yeah 100% Jake I
mean they got in town now Jake listen to
me yeah that campus me full of warlocks
well well that's by the way now hold on
now hold on bro all right because cuz if
I'm your dad like listen listen listen
to and you have to do stage doing four
years of that song so you guys see you
doing four years in the pen you're doing
four years of pain there's me all dudes
and chicks with dicks and then be smart
and we surround bite you're gonna lift
weights you can get swole with you just
the bros cuz you're not gonna wanna [ __ ]
the girls but after four years you can
get out and be free man yeah and be
smart and do good job well it's very
nice you going to the pet miss variance
you say that because when you go to
Arizona State are you gonna as you see
your yeah FSU and you go to this place
the it's literally like murderers row
when it comes to women you done Hugh not
studying high school is hot five and
number one for multiple years for
biggest party school in the u.s. yeah
correct me if I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong
me wrong let me ask you a question if
when you're a do you want a fleet I'm
today I don't know when you're a d1
athlete some of those girls some of
those girls who are now eighteen
nineteen twenty twenty-one feeling their
oats sure and fully developed women sure
and on their own for the first time and
also separated from the herd by heard I
mean they're family mommy's not there
anymore and they're carnivorous not
daddy's here no well daddy's here now
and he's young as [ __ ] to write so
doesn't like condom no as my hold on
well spread bad what peppery should wear
always but it's calling okay
experiment alright so what's on your
dick what's on mom all right well I
understand there's alcohol flowing but
some of those girls like an athlete a d1
level athlete me I am I is that am I
yeah I'd make one small correction
graduate them there we said some yes I'd
say oh and that's a thing now
when you go to another school like
Harvard or Williams were Harvard you me
alright you deal a little bit weird
nephews going you're dealing with me
warlocks and very smart people who
probably put less emphasis on their look
now I don't want say all of them have
flat asses but I'd say 99.9% of smart
women this world have a flat ass
really Oh name of valedictorian with a
fat ass I don't know I don't either bro
they're not out there God doesn't work
that I don't know I have a fat ass thing
all right you who want a fat ass front
online brains back to line really
science I haven't seen that I haven't
seen any of that but I don't have a set
of tits on him every now and then double
flapjacks yeah flapjacks there was a
girl I dated who was so beautiful so
impossibly beautiful with the biggest
perfect house hitch on the say hi Howard
sir yes dude a couple of howitzers yeah
that
you held a pencil underneath underneath
him the Penn State was fall oh and they
were real Oh what and she had the face
of an angel and legs legs and calves
high insertion calves little puckered
calves you got me yeah I'm so far full
man
yeah keep going and the flattest ass the
flattest I'm talking about back to legs
I'm out back two legs bro and I'm not
kidding it was not nothing do I was not
it was the craziest thing well now that
you know with sign I couldn't don't
inject fat into that and I wouldn't have
worked and she was not that kind of girl
I just couldn't do it at the end of the
day flat ass there is excuse me there is
nothing worse yeah it's tough it's like
dude have an ugly face there's nothing
you can do bro yeah you have like my
friend does it really funny no my friend
likes a really skinny girl with not much
of an ass at all some guys are like that
time guys are like that they're not my
friends but some guys are like it's the
what's the way it is I like I like it I
like it I like an ass of verging on
obscene oh yeah waist yeah yeah like I
know my ass is fat I know no it's a
little too much well that's it that's a
that's a situation but I'll stand I'm
having if you don't have an ass I don't
see what I mean it's so friends I do not
see you don't look at them as sexual
objects no I don't see them my eyes
threatened pick it up right no I was
born with this weird complex yeah it's
like I'm color blind of flat ass huh
like girls like hey I'm here like we're
not we're more than just nasty
I don't know yeah okay God made me this
I mean you're not exactly the feminists
friend all right dude it's not my fault
big man upstairs gave me that vision the
ass yeah blind spot yeah I'm like color
blind I only see fat asses guys in girls
really yeah guys too yeah guys shaped
like a pear there are some guys that's
another issue there are some guys out
there who are all hips and ass it's
distracting like come on bro that's
that's it that's a bummer some guys have
just a big ass dude last night was fun
though man really fun you Lea Rogan Theo
got your Gryphon the whole crew it was a
good thing man
brought my boy Jeff who who was such a
comedy fan and he just walks in and sees
everybody from Whitney to Rogen if
you're comedy fan and I'm like wow
that's like going to the pro ball if
you're a fan yeah exactly
well the Comedy Store on a Tuesday night
that there's no better spot in the world
I mean the other night it was it was it
was we were all in the bill burr
Sebastian asked I'll go Rogan I mean the
Obon keep going what more do you want it
was I was like what the [ __ ] is going on
here
good crowd had to bring you up ya little
rink their own put hands you have a
little ring low-rank
I said psoriasis and you can't wait what
dude so oh my god it's so funny yeah you
said it brings me up on stage to a full
house at the circus it's one of my best
friends my brother from another mother
he's got psoriasis it's like I'm the
[ __ ] little ring Bryan Callen oh
he really likes Lucci backstage like
getting all warmed up I'm like yeah here
we go
hey lady got psoriasis like a
[ __ ] what nobody survived really
and then and then you introduce Chris
and I think he was the best part of the
night cuz you guys just started roasting
each other yeah I was it's like I think
I was like he this guy used to open for
me and it's so fun to watch him soar now
that I've let him out the nest and and
most of the stuff I haven't written for
him but I certainly influenced his goes
Chris goes do you look you look like
every start a video game character see
he goes he goes what's weird cuz you're
talking about his hair
Brian goes dude if you better keep that
here cuz once it goes your fanbase goes
I think Chris goes yeah for sure here's
what the thing is about my hair like if
someone got lost in my soul really cuz
he goes if someone got lost in my hair
like if I boy got my hair my hair was a
forest and a boy got lost in my hair
today with a bag we can't find the boy
they would never find ever find him but
if you're a boy got lost in if your hair
was a forest I got lost near we found a
boy we thought
it's [ __ ] hilarious he's so [ __ ]
funny maze
he looks good right now - he's on this
workout program I know and he had a
jacket on All Saints jacket wasn't mad
at and had these ridiculous kicks on her
so jealous of him but he took off his
All Saints Jack and I'm like he's
staying in so I'm like dude you're
getting [ __ ] you know else's you he
jacked and I go you just working out a
lot yeah man because I just Chris will
work out every day that's one thing
about him he's trying to get his legs
bigger and that's the one thing I try to
I bring him down when I see his legs I
look at his literally nothing you can do
we have weak character weak legs weak
character and then I walk he looks good
though man I was like [ __ ] dude he's a
good-looking kid man
you know else is big whoo I grabbed and
and gave a feel down to that's better be
a surprise it was Andrew Santino Andrew
is 195 pounds and muscular you work out
yes he's got big muscular arms like I
was like what like I grabbed him I go I
go I grabbed him and I went like this
and I go 180 195 and he goes 195 dude
you know I know my men I could do it
with my hands oh my god I'm small he's
not a small guy dude I love that dude
here's a podcast that now y'all go with
big looks terrible there I in Cajun way
to pick G worst picture he's actually
bigger way bigger than Chicago kid I
think from Boston for the long house
yeah here's his own podcast now I think
it's called the sipping with the ginger
some [ __ ] like that
that's a hilarious picture but he he's
doing his own podcast and I give that
kid a listen give them a answer I know
Andrew Santino it's something Jim can
also tell what is ur game now let's find
out what his podcast is also mention hey
sha'ban Kalin made you make sure you say
that ah no I get 20% of his podcast so
it's not a big deal well you should yeah
scroll down whiskey ginger whiskey
ginger look at the logos [ __ ] good to
get on you Santino
keeps growing down chin you see it see a
bottom left there let's the legit logo I
like it it's [ __ ] good man yeah oh
he's also hilarious he's he's a great
comic god he's good man yes
is this bit about [ __ ] Tom Cruise
that just Ares [ __ ] smart yeah thanks
giving up so turkey is easy in a Mexican
household well yeah I'm uh I feel like a
refugee in my house there's no English
gone there's even Tiger speaking Spanish
like a bow hey come on I'll show flown
your dad's team here yeah let's stay in
the he's white boy size pretty Mexican
you're not that white
yeah but he's definitely going full
Mexican watching soccer and [ __ ] all
time when I come home not having that
anyways
I come home last night 1:00 a.m. from
the Comedy Store yeah me ten Joe's mom
is over our house right now and they
cooked 500 tamales Wow a lot of tamales
yeah that's only seven people coming
over tomorrow
that's a labor-intensive thing and what
they'll do is they start as him for yeah
went to 1:00 a.m. yeah oh they were
cooking tamales at four o'clock so when
you got it we still can they go to 4 2 1
a.m. so when you got home they were
still still cooking Wow that's what I
ate last night
Wow I was so hungry I missed dinner yeah
I was like y'all doing everything
they're like say no more
yeah say no more got miles and say no
more gringo I'm not even gave me [ __ ]
tamales Wow delicious they are right I
think they're gonna start selling them
they should mmm great little business
it's a good idea terrible idea but yeah
hopefully they don't food is always hard
to make money on you know I mean when
Whole Foods and erawan those places the
amount of spoilage dude I went to
everyone yesterday to pick up lunch yeah
$75 Oh yet some nerve oh really
cuz you don't throw the slogan is if
it's here it's good for you well you're
full of [ __ ] cuz I eat your pork ribs
yesterday and [ __ ] my pants yeah those
are well their food is really good but
you can get yourself a $32 gallon of
whole goat's milk no whole chicken
keep going chickens don't make milk
chickens don't make milk
chickens don't make milk so you have to
get better so you can Milly have to
guess battle kid I don't know where
you're going it gets better well it was
man weird [ __ ] it's an animal it's a
weird animal
it's a weird answer we're gonna melt
okay now look at me
ostriches don't make milk why because
they lay eggs and they're and the the
birds hold on you gotta get better
because you just said to birds and
chickens and officers don't produce milk
do they I know where you're going with
this chocolate Oh moose is not a bad
guest but no what is it they'll think of
an animal as domesticated cat cat dude
people milk a cow huh I've seen that bro
this is the best you can do with ostrich
[ __ ] chicken and cat milk I'm talking
about a gallon okay I'm getting mad
right now you better guess it right cow
[ __ ] no it's $32 why would be a cow
you're the worst you guys know cat is
getting the animal attacks even though
you're drinking gin [ __ ] ostrich and
cat that's the best you can do on a
[ __ ] cow anyone oh my god I'm getting
hot in my face feels hot right now
domesticated
yeah dude Pig just [ __ ] you can ride
it you can raw horse Mel no you can ride
no getting closer in the desert camel
milk Jesus Christ
bro Jesus [ __ ] - camel no you said cat
Pig chicken and ostrich Shambo was last
on my side there's no idea about animals
yes I do broke the door one you have no
idea what they're capable of it's air
one stop saying or wander one I don't
like when you say or want either ear one
yes ear one you know why it says air one
because it's it's if you do it backwards
it's nowhere ah why would they want the
restaurant called nowhere that's weird
it's really nowhere I think your fits in
here it's good free my god yeah I
[ __ ] walked up and down those aisles
I'm like that ain't good free that
didn't get free
yeah a lot of like I bought a shake
yesterday was $17 she gets some nerve I
know it's cozy berries and all that
it was delicious it was delicious I'm
not buying the superfood thing goji
berries and acai countenance [ __ ] off
ascites Brock delicious I'll eat
broccoli pomegranate you like
pomegranate [ __ ] I love those I grew up
my son's favorite food web anon favorite
food I grew up eating prickly pears and
pomegranate like prickly pears are
amazing especially the ones of your cat
chin you've been to Iran
I never been cat no I send a lot of
residents there though yeah it's like
it's a thinking for those people that
are they only in LA think of Whole Foods
on steroids think of Whole Foods for
absolute print it's when you're really
wealthy and you go Whole Foods doesn't
have what I want Whole Foods again too
busy for ya I'm gonna go here it's a
specialty market with crazy but they're
hot food bar yeah it's something else
bro you get your finger used to meet the
chicken fingers they got Buffalo
cauliflower yeah that's what I get I get
the chicken fingers and the Buffalo
cauliflower car I should have change
your life that's a good call right there
they got great breakfast too I got this
special you got taquitos their taquitos
with their salsa will knock your dick in
the dirt true they're always cooking
delicious and they got wonderful Pig
then they have nice up they've like
bulletproof coffee they have like
healthy shakes where you could get it
sweetened with stevia they have a mint
energizer shake now it's gonna be $18
but listen easy it's delicious yeah you
get what you pay for chin $18 that's
just know you want the Civic's of
milkshakes take your ass to Denny's you
know I'm saying Danny she's pretty you
know it has a one time I had a milkshake
at Dairy Queen it was the best day I've
ever had
hold up you had a blizzard well you know
I never ever ever drink soda or anything
and one time I remember I was like
eating healthy and somebody said here
you go and he poured me under the Hoka
Cola out of a glass bottle oh yeah it
was ice cold people are addicted the
best thing I've ever had now at my house
again it's all Mexicans one thing
Mexicans love is coca-cola not diet the
regular [ __ ] coca-cola there's all
that was in my house the past three days
I've had
the women in your family I've had three
of women in your young your girls side
of the family yeah they they what they
could eat all the food and if the weight
goes and it doesn't touch their waist
their waist goes is tiny and then it
goes into this this ridiculous ass and
they're like just to such an hourglass
yeah it's the Neal Brennan joke of if
you made a building in that shape it'd
be like that thing's not safe
that's hilarious my son has a little
rump around him too he's got a rhombus
change his diaper like dude get some ham
hug his hands are a little smaller than
mine a little tiny his fingers dude he's
got he's just a giant his fingers were
so thick I couldn't believe it they dude
but before you say milkshake again I
need you call a blizzard because they
don't do milkshakes it's a [ __ ]
blizzard wonder what's in it well it was
actually in a blizzard ah [ __ ] is that
happens that's happened Oreos dude
blizzards are so [ __ ] good
there's no Dairy Queen around there I
tried post weights in it it's [ __ ]
like the closed ones like Pasadena
they're only in malls now and they
teamed up with Orange Julius because
they're both going out of business
Oh door juice can suck this dick you're
at an Orange Julius
they suck man let me tell you something
out Orange Julius when I was a kid I
skilled Aurora Maude Bucket I'm all the
time and there's Orange Julius and my
grandma was gonna take me to go get one
and then she was trying to get her
change together cuz you know she don't
have a ton of money she was gonna change
together to pay for this small Orange
Julius and we saw the guy who's making
the because they do hot dogs there too
with Varela same thing we saw the
[ __ ] guy who's making thing pick you
pick his nose pull out a [ __ ]
cornflake oh no and we have no idea what
he did with it my grandma well we're
never going Owens Jewish again and ever
since then I met I was like six that's
one the only memories I have when those
kids CT I was [ __ ] I don't remember
anything else besides this [ __ ] [ __ ]
pulling this Raisin Bran bugger out of
his nose and putting it in the relish we
think that's nice you haven't been back
of course haven't been back dude orange
juice is disgusting yeah disgusting this
that's disgusting Oh
what's in wienie get you a blizzard
though it looks good though no no don't
eat no I'm not nope yeah it's like milk
and syrup and [ __ ] orange yeah I
can't it's like wait you where people
thought [ __ ] Jamba Juice is good for
you you are just one cup of milk 1 got
sugar 1/4 cup of sugar 1/4 cup of sugar
that much sugar Wow
oh dude it's it's not healthy for you
know a lot of sugar I love how it says
low fat okay I know what is that no
facts not good for you god damn it
one juice is terrible hmm Derek green
can do no wrong in my book though
although they were there yeah Wow keep
that [ __ ] on my face hey I'll tell you
what the who shits on all of them is you
can make fluid from McDonald's really oh
my god McDonald's never had a Laurie oh
dude what the [ __ ] man
oh no what's in that start living your
life to all this Doug there's a bunch of
different stuff it's like a thick
blizzard but it's just what's in it it's
like a hurricane of deliciousness oh
dude it's like the perfect storm of ice
cream and Oreo yeah it's a it's like
McDonald's went oh cool Dairy Milk no
you make a [ __ ] sucrose cream nonfat
milk solids corn syrup you don't read
Ian's guar gum Tiffany but now you don't
want to breathe Pingree that's [ __ ]
terrible free the point is it's
delicious yeah maybe it's not that bad
for you it's just basically milk well if
you have it you know once a blue moon
you me all right yeah you don't want to
live on it you - I've had [ __ ] Mick
floors yeah yeah I had one yesterday I
knew it - yes I do yeah so I can get
along which one did you have Oh were you
of course it pisses me off every time I
go to McDonald's and their machine is
down oh I like where I want to fight
somebody oh it's like when you go to
Disney and they're like oh I'm sorry
special queue down she looks so cute
with your he's like so I mean KAG you
know well you love McClure's yes look at
her I'm just like it's only discount
like me flurries of course she likes
eggs with
the bay the bird in it about match of
course and she likes my flare you had a
ballute McFlurry nice pollutant look
there's somebody talked me in a post
there's a store somewhere out there like
a gelato store that has balut flavored
ice cream mmm
you know that in China there's a
restaurant that serves in Beijing
there's a restaurant that serves only
come blizzards in the area what dude
there's a restaurant that source calmly
you're very close only the genitals of
animals you might want to look it up do
you know that it's a restaurant serves
only the genitals of animals in this is
where China yep you can eat the dick and
balls of pretty much any animal really
uh-huh we it's just a gimmick but you
know in China they do well China China
that you would eat everything every part
of the animal because people didn't have
yeah but just dick I believe its heaters
we think it's an aphrodisiac oh that's
right don't they like rhinoceros dick in
horns cuz I think it's gonna make him
like immortal or some [ __ ] yeah nineteen
are you still killing [ __ ] rhinos for
the famous restaurant it's a real place
yep let's go ahead and see wait play
that Andrew Zimmern Guo Lee's Wang is
said to be the world's first penis
restaurant Wow
interesting you can sort of tell what
kind of restaurant it is by the artwork
the Chinese believe that the penis holds
especially concentrated nutritional
benefits there's more than what a lot of
American Girl righties offered here from
deer and sheep to ox and seal don't let
CEO excited look there are lots of
restaurants in the world a looks like a
daughter to penis dishes on the menu but
I've never been in a restaurant that
specializes in only so you know how many
times are we gonna have this opportunity
many of the dishes are thought to have
specific benefits snake penis is
supposed to be good for the kidneys
whole big as that by tiny yeah yeah yeah
for sure yeah I could not eat that you
wanna see like like [ __ ] fear factor
I throw up everywhere
really oh dude I seen a penis is much
softer and that it is playboy I bet it
is
mine is bigger huh oh oh Jesus Christ
maybe there's try the other one the
other one is little it's very good for
your kidneys and for your skin it hats
bones Tigers penis is 1500 that's few
two tigers penis [ __ ] you man
what else do they keep going chin yeah
keep going what else that what else does
that guy eat in that video though I'll
just keep watching it yeah I like to see
the actual dicks they're eating next
we're trying deer penis sliced and fried
deer penis I bet that's right that's
like right your Mountain Oysters
anything fried taste tells it that looks
good I bet it does but it almost has a
very neutral flavor like cartilage like
tendon could you eat that no not throw
up no I don't want it
I don't want to eat a dick I'll be
muscleman I'm not even the animals day
the realest thing you've ever said I
don't eat dick yeah on stage in light
animal that that's a nurse that's a baby
see notice seahorse animals the animals
will eat turtle penis alright try the
yak penis
oh that one is so chewy and this is just
I don't like how excited he is to eat
all these dicks yaks
why is he so into these dicks a sadness
he saw did he look he literally looks
like it dick the turtles [ __ ] up man
in there that looks like that's it I
don't think there's no dick restaurants
in the United States I'll see illegal a
lot of that [ __ ] well it's probably
illegal but yeah they'll eat everything
I'm assuming there'd be no one there
right I mean that's up for a few weirdos
it's just not my thing
eating balls dick I just don't want I
tried rock to buy an oysters on a road
trip one time you know lions and hyenas
when they take and wild dogs when they
take down a buffalo or any animal they
eat the buffalos well you know
Rosewood's the buffalos fighting off
these lions they eat your testicles and
testicles index you're right
you've seen the video some posts just
tagged me in a video of it and this
[ __ ] hyena has this water buffalo and
he's dick first and the water Bravo's
like running away and the hyenas just
walked on on this dick and it's like
stretching all know that nature is awful
and then someone else tagged me in a
video this beer I don't know where
they're at
this guy's a pig farm and the pigs like
against the fence and this beer is just
like just eating this pig alive are they
your life yeah and it doesn't find that
it's on nature's mantle or whatever the
[ __ ] damn okay bears are no joke man try
killing a pig with your hands and mouth
good luck it's very difficult to do okay
all right there the first one this one
yeah watch this everybody seems this guy
has zero [ __ ] given to what are you
gonna do to the pig in the back oh it's
in that this is in um oh that's really
that pig give me no life that bear
reached over and grabbed him this little
moving he's ripping his skin off is that
because the in the pig can't get away
Dan that's so cruel it'll ruin your day
that's so cruel
doctor shoot that pig in the head
if you want something let's let's change
the subject go to my Instagram do you
see the video posted this this dude
singing with his daughter no by the best
video I've ever posted recently uh
bottom left oh I did see this one see
this pregnancy's look at her lip singing
she knows all the words watch your
little voice oh my god no what oh my god
[Music]
how cute is that [ __ ] video oh my
gives me chills
she's just a dog you can tell the dad
just loves the [ __ ] outta better I love
her and I don't even know her how do you
everybody how cute is this video Nature
has created a situation where you you
you love her but how great is that she
knows the little little song she's so
cute how [ __ ] cute is that did I miss
that age when I could wrap my little son
of my daughter in a little like a
blanket night with teetee I want a girl
so there like a little Rita I want to
show that I do too now I thought she was
smaller actually she's not me 3 that's a
three or three and a half I just sold me
this three is an adorable age it's
impossible it's impossibly adorable it
everybody needs a daughter now got a she
cute right oh so tagging that video mic
hole we've got a personality what a
great personality already little voice
yeah it's funny all kids have different
personalities my niece's have told and
they're amazing duty yesterday my son's
school had like their little
Thanksgiving thing he surprised all the
kids with Thanksgiving and the parents
bring all their stuff and I found it
fascinating all the kids everyone's
different man
some kids are super polite doing a thing
or anything some kids are there on their
own
some kids are causing ruckus kids are
super impolite it's fascinating
khalil gibran the great poet said your
children come through you and not yours
what the problem is especially the some
of the schools in LA you know where the
parents have money or their celebrity
stuff like that a lot of these kids
don't have a connection to the the
parents because they're raised by
nannies because the pants are so busy
yeah man and let me tell you this in the
circles that I'm in you can tell which
kids those are literally like this I can
tell right away I know it's such a
bummer
there's no connect there's just no
connection kid doesn't listen to them
but listen to the nanny the kid it's not
good man it's heartbreaking see I got
worth it soon as soon as I know parents
like that I'm you checked out check your
off you don't even I came in look at him
just like yeah I know a big celebrity
and his wife and they were they just
were never there and that boy he was
four at the time and he was raised by
nannies oh dude I had this this dad tell
me that it doesn't go mice this is not
anyone at my son's school this is
outside time at the playground and I'm
talking to this nanny and nice lady
Mexican lady nah she's a lady she was 22
young and I went oh is that your chunks
they don't look that the kids widest
[ __ ] she's Mexican she's oh no I'm his
Nana go that's cool
and I said well the pants do and there's
I know they live in bel-air
and how long do you have him she goes oh
Monday through Sunday I have him from
when he wakes up to he goes to bed she's
like white and like where's his parents
at like they're around but I usually I
do all them I do everything I put him to
bed wake up with him feed them I'm like
they must be paying a bank that yeah
well [ __ ] what they and then I go then
when they get older every child what are
you doing
they that's the way they view it you
know this to them it's like well then
you do it and then most have you out
like we get all the good stuff like we
play with the Quixote in the movies but
when it comes doing outsource to a
rental [ __ ] you outsource the bonding is
when you do that I don't know when the
kids sick and stuff that's when you get
closest yeah cuz kitchen rely on you
Wow you keep those kids I'm telling you
at the plane tip dome right right right
if there's no connection no [ __ ] I just
have no respect for that man oh god I
just don't I mean I know listen I have
respect for sometimes parents have no
money and they have to work
they have no choice that's a different
thing it's a different thing when you
have that much money and you what are
you doing like what exactly you pay that
nanny I mean you're talking low six
figures yeah shitload of money yeah it's
a weird thing I don't get it either dude
people make these choices I see this a
lot in in LA and New York and in
anywhere that where people have really
decided that they're gonna chase that
dollar and build crazy wealth lose track
of things
a lot of times you lose connection you
know lose community you lose time and
you definitely lose your kids yep Jim
you are new 40th [ __ ] do you don't want
kids for your [ __ ] you don't kids not
like I'm not like crazy about having
kids but I eventually have kids like
maybe not young you're older and you're
dude I think it's fine you think yeah
may i got to-- 45:41 be 50 not only be
good be it have my first kid at 50 no I
don't want to do that no there was like
oh cool your Grandpa's here right now
it's my dad bro yeah but if I don't have
a kid then our family names gone my
brother's not gonna have me cause your
brother doing it he doesn't want kids
he's like my brother he doesn't have
kids J does not want kids my brother's
no even if [ __ ] look at cars no well
would you say your brother what he
doesn't want to get married
does he have a girlfriend a girlfriend I
just want to get married how long have
they been together three years
interesting dynamic brother yeah what's
he do he's a chief IT officer at a
company smart guy it's very smart guy
he's in the same field as J oh yeah
they're they work for a competing
company or some [ __ ] no no you're safer
drives a cool car does he have a gt3 as
a GTR GTR China which I think it's still
for his age he could afford something
different and like the seat when I look
at GTRs will bring up a GT engine so 200
with the [ __ ] were time it's a Nissan
GTR there are monsters affordable
especially how fast they're ridiculous
card to get it home Godzilla
and he could promise it's like a
grown-up Havana and this is no hate at
all but especially for a guy who's twice
at least early thirties early thirties
it's a [ __ ] beast performance-wise
looks great everything but when I see it
I just I don't really take you serious
as a grown man you feel like it's a
busted-up version of a Porsche or
something else no it's amazing car and
it's just that it's very fast and
furious how much does it cost
it's in the hundreds he bought it for
like a hundred seven thousand oh it's
that expensive yeah it's what it is for
what it is it's faster than cars way
more expensive now Wow it's a monster
but it's a I don't think I'll go out the
way it looks but also it's it's um they
look cool in person yeah it's a [ __ ]
great car yeah it's just not my thing
yeah even for me I'm telling him like
you could afford something if it's only
mature for a guy in his forties right
[ __ ] yeah to me and get a porter I'm
gonna get something way cooler
what do you harm it's almost like I
don't know it's like when I see guys in
their 30s driving Corvettes or in the
four-ton like thank you all right so
let's talk about my next car because I
have my Lisa's up on my test leg like
really I could bike a trade in right now
or you know but like do you like the
testicle arch you like driving that I do
mmm it's a great car it's a great car
the problem is plugging it in yeah being
it's just annoying sometimes I'd like
the option of having a gas tank so
having said that what would you say is a
good car for me like a Porsche guy here
man
well no I think a Jayne 11s for you 911s
a 911s I think so it looks sick this hat
back seat sir no it's a probably doing
for your kids yeah see you tell me that
bro I need all the [ __ ] untilthe it
yeah I'm gonna need to put my kids there
back to okay amber Guinea just came out
of the SUV I'm bored Guinea Lambo Gill
is weird
it looks [ __ ] pretty safe though oh
you but you know what's equivalent to
that and looks I think better will that
be have you got that Brian we would get
way closer as friends
really ah got the interiors stupid show
Brian the price of that though for me
that a nice car yes definitely the best
SUV but the thing that comparable that
is the 208 2 X 7
yeah I don't want to spend that much
money I don't know what you're looking
for here bro
you got that Goldberg money I don't know
what's going on with the old you get the
Audi Q I think it's the q8 it's the new
one but it's the same body and chassis
as the Lamborghini and and the interior
stupid there it is it looks nice the q8
my my sister-in-law is getting it my
brother's life just got hers yeah black
on black on black scar huh
ridiculous really do you unless you've
either I don't know you never know with
me you know I'm different like when a
lot of poor she get the Panamera
four-door that might be a that's a coin
that's cool now it's not gonna be cheap
that's a lot of Porsche Panamera for my
GTS worried about 180 180 it's a Porsche
sir I don't want that one that's that
expensive what see the first thing I
don't want to spend it anymore I'm a
hundred grand is too much well the test
over at 70 yeah look I spend it's it
that wouldn't you lease it it's a grand
a month that's I don't want spending the
way I put some money down you know to
get those payments I'm sure you used
Bentley like a flying squirrel though I
think I'm gonna stick with a Tesla huh
yeah I like that Porsche when you guys
were talking about Porsches I was like
you know you know it has better pickup
than a portion every other car Tesla's
mmm what do you mean you're saying zero
to 60 yeah
I'm saying zero to 60 electric all right
I'm gonna say this to you don't try to
get don't try to jump off a pilot grillo
has that dodge 800 horsepower try to
drag race with me good ol Bry beat him
no no wait a the side and I know
everyone's like that's a Tesla's like
pitching point to guys like that yeah if
we're on the 405 and there's like court
like let's say we're down sunset korma
havoc and I'm racing you and Grillo
quarter-mile my car is doing this all
over you so you don't know I have enough
lock in you on must I'll tell you what
[ __ ] I got the the hundred doesn't
matter here you're a car you laughing
the track are you kidding I was laughing
you with the hundred the ludicrous
package oh my god do you poor things and
for all you poor thing here you're like
wow you're May you're noisy
but noisy but your guess who's coming
out of electric car to Porsche that's
just gonna [ __ ] on all the Tesla's I
want that comes out next year then ain't
for you it's too much for you too much
in every fastest too much price looks I
think it's come out as a reasonable
price probably not maybe the most
reasonable Porsche right doesn't happen
huh I'm [ __ ] LeConte
I gotta stick with with the Tesla that's
not gonna look like that though right
yeah if it does that's amazing
that's a nice looking for you Brian
please there's electric truck coming out
I have a deposit on it really yeah it's
called the bill injure really you have a
deposit on it I really like that car
well that's the Cayenne you get that -
dude my brother lock J's gonna hear this
thing soon you like 70 options unless
you get okay do that J send it to me the
tight a can you all you Nevada shows
next week LA Auto Show those are all
prototypes no no no not the Auto Show
look at that right there
that's what supposed to look like dude I
mean that's an amazing looking car yeah
enough for you
ah but we should go the well you should
go the Auto Show I go every year but I
want to be in that car
well if you wanna drop you know - 300
grand do it do you think it's gonna cost
that much not gonna be cheap I don't
have money I can never justify spending
$200,000 on my car even if I had it I'd
be like Corte I'm not a car guy but you
drop [ __ ] tons of money on wine that
didn't last I know 300 horsepower
electric drivetrains
there were 1635 yeah that crazy what I
love guys like you who can't get enough
you like it's not that crazy
look sick though because I'm just not
into electric cars i off sam enough to
come around like a dinosaur but
eventually my son's Friday night you
know most get a lot of kids arm you in
the driver license cuz uber that was
like why would I ever do it well they're
gonna it's not gonna be over it's gonna
be driverless yeah but I'm saying kids
right now they're just like why the [ __ ]
right I can go anywhere I want with this
app sure little bastards does want to be
free men down that road
there's not a better drive than when I
leave the Tommy store at one o'clock in
the morning and I go down Sunset
Boulevard and there's ero people on the
road I put in sport mode now if we get
pulled over
I'm gonna go to jail I'm going about 140
down this right yes I've never seen a
cop or anything now you can talk to
listen this I'm gonna take it but the
point is it's a great time and I jump
from there to the 405
oh and daddy's going you're going fast
so I can open up its when you open her
up and she needs to be opened up a
little doctor she remind to refer to
your cars she or he is usually caught
darkwing duck and he's a dude oh yeah
so he might be a man you know I say to
myself I'll get on the 405 lines just
silently in my head go let's get
dangerous really yeah you know what I
say I go let's go fast but stay safe
that's why I say I go let's let's push
this bad boy up to 80 you know I thought
about last night as I'm going about a
hundred down Santa Monica Boulevard
around these crazy corners my cars just
gripping like a gecko I'm thinking to
myself I didn't go deposit sperm right
you'll die fairly soon if I keep this up
yeah but I want my legacy to live on I
need to spot its sperm and you know what
they can do they can save the sperm you
know I could do so even if I die my girl
girls can still go to this dick doctor
and get pregnant or that's was all
that's what I was thinking for you yeah
if you're old you have your old brother
over here your older brother step in
raise your kids proper when I can raise
them I need my relationship yeah let's
move them into a compound well because
you know that I'm there for her no I
know but I'm there my DNA
I don't want your well we could always
have that too and I'll raise your kids
is my own that's fine but I'd just be
daddy I'll be daddy mmm there's a new
sheriff in town and he's had some of
those tamales please only go and strike
up the tomorrow you have some in tamales
and we're gonna make some noise mamacita
let's get some eyes let's put the kids
to bed put the kids bed in that
soundproof room
make some noise alright and if you want
dude yeah I'm real sad I need to cry of
a Brendan and then well you now you open
your Porsche up at night the same thing
my voice is real real it's real real
salty dude salt give your Invisalign a
right now yeah I'm wearing my stuff to
win oh you know these are mind you teeth
are fighting it yep I'm so sorry I got
keep them on if you knew it they're
fighters bro so I can see him vying for
a position that's what happens so I can
seem like I got a room at night and now
I'm like walking around we had a talk I
goes guys been [ __ ] around I guess
he's got one in the trying to move back
again he well she's back he's back he's
like I'm going back again no you're not
so I got to keep him under wraps he's in
the prime of bus he's in timeout
brother bus he's in timeout he and it
hurts when I am worn it in two days
I have to put him back in he's like ah
your teeth hurt for a little bit it
hurts right now did you do stand-up less
than your Invisalign
no I always take him out bill burr does
stand-up in his Invisalign he hasn't
been sewing - I think he's done with it
now are you done with it for life or no
yeah but you gotta wear a retainer are
your [ __ ] teeth will go back to where
they were they don't tell you you can
actually grow the bone normally when you
need to it just takes time really
probably braces are the only way to go
metal braces cat let me see your teeth
great great great
yeah braces I had braces when I was a
kid I had a really gnarly underbite
really mm-hmm
the braces fix under bite um I get fix
mine really yeah
Cheney uh braces never let me see your
teeth you remember you looked at him
before now let me see him
good teeth no they're all right great
this letter shoot him straight now you
as a TV personality you have to get your
teeth done I'm gonna get veneers really
are veneers you have to be careful of
though because they tend to look fake oh
no they don't have fake choppers but you
don't need it it's like your girl's fake
tape you might know [ __ ] there might be
so you can do where you can actually get
your teeth first straighten with
Invisalign let me see you got a lot of
unevenness in you
teeth some teeth decided I'm gonna grow
big you know I'm saying though no I
don't know what you're sure you talk
about a sideline you're like you [ __ ]
now they look good now dude who told you
that
my teeth are all on one level dude does
not know they're on well there's still
nah bro your teeth look great
your teeth are on your team for look
like you're living a wave god these look
like they're constantly doing the wave
well that's not true your teeth go like
this if I had to drive my teeth I get so
carsick you know you know what happens
is these two bodies aren't too bad look
yeah they're starting to know they've
always been that way yeah now are they
white no they're not who's not yours
today is not winning any crest
commercials is Joe Rogan [ __ ] last night
how about our line and I don't like was
admin I go to high-five him I hit him
right in the eye he goes to [ __ ] slap
his hand and he catches his [ __ ] nose
and I with his finger like really hard
job oh Jesus Christ I know him I bet you
basically back hey yeah yeah you slap
him in the face
well good ceiling he went in fast yeah I
thought my eye was distance time and
even backwards he came away dude now
that I have Invisalign let me start over
the team I noticed everybody's teeth
real quick he has a you know this famous
guy animal handler no I don't the real
Tarzan or something no all right so he
has the craziest veneer things is your
Wow African elephant did you see foot
great but they look so fake though don't
they yeah again it's like girls faked it
we all know they're fake but they very
appealing yeah and you can actually get
Lanier's that look you can yeah the
right guy all right no no here's look
like he looks like the mask
yeah just Robin's teeth somewhere yeah
by the way Rodan could give a [ __ ] but
still don't know don't try come rub now
nah he's all up in his goddamn back up
Sparky um maybe just Google Joe Rogan
froggen teeth I don't know if you need
Rogen teeth you can just zoom in oh
there you go
all right yeah I'll see you when you're
looking down at them
no even there they're not great listen
no one in this room besides cats win an
award for it to me I have good teeth now
you do not have good teeth whoever's
telling that it's full of [ __ ] actually
I told row gum get veneers and he was
like whatever bro look at that funny how
you can how the algorithm is so good and
so quick daddy that's amazing who is the
best teeth that we know they're veneers
bro
everyone does D'Elia D'Elia has good
teeth probably sometimes you can't see
up in theirs cuz their lips sometimes
you don't know till Jesus Christ when
this is super blue those are good teeth
yeah yeah there you go I've never looked
at Theo Steve that can't be good being a
redneck it's just on their DNA most
people like me people Jews people my
family's all in English so dirty
my grandma's teeth she got all her teeth
removed when she was like 24 yeah
some people have English you say you
know what [ __ ] it I think Theo probably
had braces so his teeth look good I
don't think so they look great
I'll have to see him I know who he's
trying to fool there that he's happy
though yeah they look really good that
looks like a cool cover
yeah if you like hey Theo you skip paid
to do he looks like a point it dude I
remember I'll never forget I'll never
forget I stated this restaurant and this
[ __ ] stud and he was from Spain and
he was jacked handsomest [ __ ] and was
macho and would date he was a well I
found out later cuz he was training me I
found out he was a Nazi basically like
he was a what for real like a like he
was so shockingly on Isis he was just so
shockingly racist against Jews and
and anybody who was of a certain ilk
there and I think wait I had to stop
training with him because I we had there
and he started talking about how he was
literally lucky he only dated Germans
and Aryans is there any more wheels like
for real he wants to say that be I was
just watching American History X last
night mm-hmm
hard to watch I turn to my son Isaac and
I realized when I rise so then I use so
much up and he'd say stuff like this
he'd go do it do it parking keep it
there keep it there and I go I'm trying
to go he'd go um he'd go I got can't do
it you can and you will you can and you
will so he was just an insane guy and he
was just a bodybuilder meanwhile he
[ __ ] that I find out yeah the women
that owned the restaurant they come up
and they go you'll never guess you'll
never guess what Fernanda does he's gay
and I go when he was did gay porn and he
was he had done a bunch of sources but
he had girls he had he dated girls but
he had done a bunch of gay porn and man
gahafer pays what they call you yeah I
don't know or in my book I just gay yeah
well [ __ ] guys on camera and your
dick is hard you even paid apparently I
didn't see him at the girls tell me he
had a giant dong which made sense but
God bless him dick but he was a rate of
not see a gay Nazi Spaniard outstanding
kiss trainer kid I just couldn't do it
I'll do it I just got a man I can't just
if you're racist you you gotta be so
stupid
it was shocking they were just showing
they stop that you just gotta your
intelligence level I just can't [ __ ]
with you man yeah but I was watching
American History X last night dude when
he curbs that dude when that when they
robbed his house and he's you [ __ ] with
the wrong white boy and he puts the gun
to saying just put your teeth on the
curb that it's hot I've got how intense
that is and then the guy's teeth on
which makes me also that comes from so
the curve the guy that told him that is
someone that I actually know would mean
told him so so he went and talked to a
bunch of skinheads I'm sure and you know
this isn't Venice but and in Washington
DC the whole taste yeah this takes place
in Venice Beach when they're playing
basketball and all that stuff this is
Cal foot that happened to the dude in DC
that we knew no Kirby's what they've
done with their thing right off will
they kill them
the aura just takes all your teeth out
[ __ ] up your heavy it's the worst thing
in the world it's so that there's such
and it's such a well made movie but it's
so [ __ ] intense men the part where
there's teeth is just kind of rattling
on the cement right it makes your teeth
15-2 says controversial cutscene so they
cut that scene out I saw it so yeah well
he hid under reset link that's at that
link chin because me is there more to
that Kirby scene just trying to destroy
a human being the at curb stop do you
ever watch TV would you say for TV when
they took it not last night on AMC they
played the whole thing that's justice
here though yeah I don't like that [ __ ]
man cuz hey cuz it happened here's the
original scene I'm sure you got taken
down yeah I'm sure it's done oh no watch
do you want to be so I don't like it I
don't like saying that stuff it's I mean
how good of a [ __ ] actors
[Music]
kill those to town yeah whatever
happened that they were Robin Hood what
happened ahead of it for long is that
the kid in the movie
[Music]
they just [ __ ] with the wrong ball so
intense man see I beg you better shut up
on my mouth on this shoot me I'd really
go out with a gun to the head nobody he
knows he's gonna get killed though you
know yeah this is where it's
uncomfortable it's well done good
filmmaking dude I'll show you what it
was about just that right there that
looks like teeth [ __ ] it's the most
intense part of any movie of all time
that's pretty awful
it was prison - yeah yeah but yep you've
never seen that movie cat I've heard of
it but because of this scene I've never
got around to watching it make sense
with the good you're doing yourself a
disservice if you think like like I
don't see how it's racist cuz B it's
pretty cool because he goes to prison
because he murdered black people yeah
and in prison he becomes best friends
with a black guy then he gets out and
he's like this what the [ __ ] was I doing
they tried to give his brother out of it
it's a great story man Edward Norton
such a good eye holders yeah and I think
what's one of the original investors in
a company called Twitter and made 300
million dollars and said see he was he's
I've had a couple of long conversations
with him he's one of the smartest people
I've ever spoken so I heard he's dick
you know he's they're smart and then
there's Ed Norton he was I went to Yale
and he got he was low Duty brilliant guy
he's a brilliant [ __ ] too smart
for his own good probably hard to work
with you know cuz would come up with his
own ideas and he does but if he doesn't
need to do [ __ ] he's now do you think
I'm just spitballing here do you think
he did all the winstrol in the world to
get ready for American as well actually
I was when I was accused in height and
else in the 90s I don't long talk with
him when he was getting ready for it and
he was he's not that big when I saw him
when he was just about to shoot it
wasn't when strong date he was just
eating he's pretty tall well he's always
told me well I heard her interview he
goes everyone always asked like oh he
was I was you guys everyone thinks I was
so jacked in American history yeah yeah
he goes it was no he said it was the
angles and then yeah shading yeah and a
lot of it's black and whites yes big and
he's by the way he's not you know he's
like me a little bit taller maybe maybe
my higher a little more most yeah a
little barely but I mentally month if
you lift a lot and eat a lot he's a
really disciplined guy his height weight
there click on that link chin I mean I
think he's 511 175 on but what was Eve 6
feet 174 yeah but what was he for
American History X alright has a little
bit of the yeah it doesn't say there oh
what's that
he said these are true intellectual like
really smart guy just spends his time
reading and writing yeah it's like when
guys are like dude I won't look like
Brad Pitt from Fight Club like you do
you know how [ __ ] small he is yeah
he's tight especially in that he was Tom
and Louise
he's 145 look it was and in thumbin
Louise you'll see how Sal how thin he
was Brad Pitt your semen s don't win
Louise oh yeah is the firt that was his
breakout role no that was his breakout
role oh my god I can't believe you
haven't seen this this is great
Delmon Louise watch this right right
there play the clip
play that which one right there what you
do oh man your bank robber no would you
rob hmm well I see
chat it up here I robbed a gas station a
couple means to die me pee thing stores
just made them still Bobby it's still
bodied up there you'll see now you'll
see how skinny I know be still bodied up
still ripped ripped City shreds very
skinny okay
well she first pinkie pie's his arms
yeah I mean he doesn't look like the
movie Troy but still pretty shredded not
tight a little Kermit on yeah but a good
a good frame he's gonna get up and dance
watch ladies slow didn't really say she
wins price keeping her that crazy that's
pretty as he gets older put on muscle
yeah yeah funny everyone thinks up from
the if you look at his frame on Fight
Club chin he's not like not a jack he's
not playing football now on Fight Club I
have it on good authority that he
probably had some supplementation help
and as well as in Troy there is so in
the movie snatch to he's yeah yeah there
was some there was a jar some help there
was yeah dude again if Hollywood's like
a shop we want to be in this movie era
and you have 12 weeks yeah I'm calling
up anyone I know at [ __ ] Gold's like
a whatever the rocks take and send that
that's right and it looks good on camera
you see the rock when he first got to WV
mmm-hmm once I was being stung by all
the pineapple bees he was super chunky
he doesn't like anything like you just
look down I like him yes I look better
back there no way look like me back so
what I like that loaded face I like that
I like the big I don't like them
shredded I think shred is [ __ ] I
like I like the Samoan looked around a
little but are you alright
those are glory days chin for the love
of God scroll up so you throw far left
if you go to them just type in the rock
early days Jesus
WWE WUF WWF first match I'll just watch
a video hater the shredded [ __ ] with all
the steroids I think it's gross
there you go look good you look like a
normal man don't you see like his face
how you had like like it stung by a
bunch of [ __ ] honeybees he was young
there was more fat in your face when
you're younger yeah yeah I'm not that
young though you know I'm saying and
then you look at him now he's fun look
at him now well it [ __ ] shredded City
yeah but it's yeah I hate that huh well
I don't like artificial looks like that
this is weird to me it's just vain and
weird and useless muscle
I like the [ __ ] right you know I like
you like your man's like an athletic
looking dude like like you don't like
you always think you look heavy or
something like that cuz you're not
shredded but I think that's the fact
what a man looks like I'd rather look
like that Oh remember when he first got
Dollywood he was doing my thing and
tried he got super skinny cuz I thought
he thought that's why Hollywood wanted
they got skinny was and the song is what
the [ __ ] you doing shave your head like
a meathead and take all the steroids
yeah and there's a booming booming yeah
business is a big guy naturally he does
30,000 movies a year yeah that's him and
walk tall on the left there I like that
better this [ __ ] his bodybuilder
[ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ]
although he's got can I see his tits
there well we got surgery for it first I
know yeah I said well he called it
something else it was like some sort of
birth thing that he had I know that's
what it is
I'm not mad at anyone I celebrate it
good for him
I'm gonna have to do the old roids 160
you're never gonna do it be no dude him
in that movie was it was he called
what's up
scroll down chin seemed the lifting
movie there was that movie called
with Marky Mark didn't do so well I love
that movie I never saw it was it good
yes now go get in there look at how [ __ ]
he's playing a guy on steroids in that
movie though he was yeah look at his
[ __ ] neck dude you see Mark Wahlberg
that oh god whatever we called I look
looking up right now uh-huh
no dude painting hey gain what is it
called painting gain they've they're
both steroid dudes all of them got on
this saucy sauce again if my agent calls
late Hey Dude they don't you be in
painting game you're playing a guy
[ __ ] distribute steroids
say no more fam he's gone hey where you
headed Oh Gold's Gym I'm on my way to
Gold's on that's not an excuse how fun
would that be though if you have the
right doctor who can get you back I'll
get more homeboy do you think they
called each other and totally each other
what cycles they're running I do Diamont
so much when strong about to [ __ ] I
got death hair coming out my dick
that's hilarious oh my god
chin would you ever do steroids yes why
not do them dude did you see if you know
really yeah way too quick you have no
reason not to look into the whole TRT
stuff I mean again dude with kids and
trt like that young bro let's know this
is when you say ball right around 40
right your level that's how you feel you
know how do you feel I gotta get in
shape with your I know guys who've done
and and their blood pressure is high and
it's my fancy lipid levels cuz your
energy level right now chin it always
seems pretty the Energy's always here
yeah never seems pretty low but that
might be your personality yes no
exercise doesn't eat that well there's a
lot of ways pretty decently yeah it's
just that I don't work out that well
yeah yeah I think exercise is really
good for your hormonal levels sure I
agree a releases endorphins and and
hormones I mean can you actually spike
your test on if you still work out a lot
of no much anymore to work so much yeah
do you eat well I know you have good
genetics mmm
sometimes I try and then sometimes I eat
like an [ __ ] like five weights and
five pounds in like a week
does your what's your man built like a
pretty slim guy yeah me yeah like you
get hungry once you put on muscle pretty
well if he works out he used to break
dance so he was pretty he would get my
yeah I was like that girl who never grew
out of being attracted to like
breakdancers you should have grew out of
it I school great no beep yeah [ __ ] I'll
be dancing yeah both of us used to dance
that's how we met
oh really you dance yeah used to be a
hip-hop dancer you guys Rana you damn
yes you started kpop band I kept on
there that's cool you know that one of
us are a Korean though whoa see what see
what do they let me know but you know
these kpop just Koreans I think now that
the King kpop stamp for Korean pop yes
it does yes but I think kpop so popular
now that there are like black girls in
kpop there Chinese girls in kpop because
we don't call black bands be pop bebop
or white pop I think it's more of like a
genre of music more like any aging to be
kpop yeah but so Japanese are j-pop it's
just so good rhythm and blues rapping
[ __ ] so you would say these things we
actually forget what they actually I
know you just think yeah I'll do it
um so you're man does he work out or no
no now he's basically just video games
well he just plays jay-z on Twitch and
[ __ ] trying to make money not trying to
make money but he'll make youtube videos
based off of like super into it yeah
super indie game destiny never heard of
it yeah destiny destiny and so but why
didn't get on Twitch to make money cuz
if he's making videos like I don't like
that that gamer [ __ ] uh what's the
fighter's name uh Sean O'Malley yeah
he's on Twitch you saying makes forty
five hundred a month at least just
people watching play
I'll see your man sighs famous too Sean
O'Malley shouts Sean O'Malley but you
can make real money which people watch
less you know what the [ __ ] you're doing
I think right now the big thing with
twitches like uh they have a lot of like
hot girls coming in trying to game and
it's just like their tits are out and
don't like leave random [ __ ] like
they'll leave like a dildo in the
background and waiting for people like
oh what's that in the back no like oh no
this whole thing I can't believe I left
it out yeah damn I'm so into twitch now
damn we need to get on Twitch dude
twenty nine dollars a year top earners
top ten I think it's funny when people
but see this is the same reaction of you
will do when like do you have to make
money podcast right now like what you
shooting me that's pretty much money so
my friends make from podcasting Daniel
but even twitch like Jim kids are bought
YouTube some of youtubers are making
more than anyone on TV you see some
podcasts are making more than anyone you
know on TV that's not even close a month
I know how much some of these TV actors
get paid how much we get paid like and
how much you're not worth how much you
get yourself into podcast crazy um your
man just plays a ton of video games huh
yeah if he's not working he's playing
video games what's he do for work uh he
works in his family's business it's like
a Filipino like makeup distributor so he
just balls dude do you play the games
with them or no no I like watching
people play game self do you really yes
sighing [ __ ] that's what twitches though
people want yeah I [ __ ] hate watch I
want to play it watches these games he
watches people playing it
that's that switch seven years old
that's a lot of their biggest
demographic it's like kids not even just
that yeah I think it's the personality
that they stick around for why don't you
play it but you want to I see his face
as he's playing the game sounds like
similar to like reality TV show like why
would you watch somebody else's life but
why are you watching somebody play a
video game that you could play yours I
don't know how to feel about it because
it's like it's so addictive to kids and
I super addicted like you my son has to
gets ten minutes on than ten minutes off
of exercise his roms or something you
guys are dicks so he can't get in a
rhythm so you can only do ten minutes of
video then play the drums I give them a
little more but yeah this is channel do
it too much I was just going to some
Korean events cool happy thanks so actor
David Arquette the other day there were
a few videos coming out where he was in
a wrestling death match so it's like a
more
version of WWE I guess he's trying to
get into that whole scene and something
went wrong he had a light bulb hit over
his head he left bleeding and a lot of
people are freaking out they also didn't
know why he was wrestling
I guess that's his new endeavor really
mm-hmm
did you see my girl Esther who's
probably the best photographer on the
[ __ ] planet for as far as far as
combat sports and wrestling goes she's
so good she took all the pics for this
fueled her her shed it her pictures are
insane he's getting got [ __ ] up is
this the video of it
this is video their little Club please
don't watch this video if you're
bothered by blood harcourt wrestling
that's a bad idea
oh [ __ ] he's sticking in his face is
that David Arquette on the ground mm-hmm
that's him standing up on all right yeah
what's wrong with David's on top yeah at
this point his neck is bleeding cuz a
piece of glass are slit it dami cut his
neck yeah a piece of the lightbulb
shattered and a slew his neck on the way
down don't break a lightbulb on somebody
well that's wrestling bro it's real to
me goddamn it real to me holy [ __ ] man
he's jacked up he's going back in
where's the medics what is that matter
what is getup doing here what is he he
just ran out of ideas what is he doing
this again oh [ __ ]
so is this it's all fake there's nothing
fake but I mean so this is definitely
staged the thing that he said he
released a tweet about it was that the
reason why it went so south was because
of his inexperience and that he didn't
know what he was doing
let's just cut that bad or he should
have been cut at all but I guess it was
a freak accident on top of him not
knowing how to do the moves correctly
yeah I
I don't know turns out death matches
aren't my thing yeah that's hilarious
he's a nice guy
yeah if you go to Esther's Instagram
chin she's a [ __ ] monster she had
some dope pics of it it's like him
jumping off a [ __ ] seven storey
building some [ __ ] yeah what's her
Instagram is what all Eldad all elbows
if you want some of the best pictures
you ever see check her out she does all
the photography for the UFC Showtime
she's a [ __ ] monster super slow
internet huh super slow I like help nice
and cool isn't here these days look at
that that's David Arquette I mean I
don't look she's put dude he's doing
dude it's crazy man look at that [ __ ]
she has a pig I want to see post it she
has this picture from a UFC fight a few
weeks ago
oh this Dugan punched in the mouth and
it's the perfect timing and the blood is
like [ __ ] go back to page Jen's got a
refresh it around there oh there it is
oh well - hold up look it go down look
at that an elbow she got from Yair and
we get his pictures that's why she's the
best for timings I said look at that
easy cuz you anything about it's 3 to 1
well she's probably doing a shot like
film but most we want to shoot that [ __ ]
in real time like keep that and there's
another one where it's a punch to the
[ __ ] face and the blood is coming out
more recent called far-right guys leave
that leave the blood so I'm gonna be a
fighter huh leave that gnarly huh yeah
great picture though oh my god very cool
man yep incredible
she's only took picture of me and uh
Deonte on the bus was just a moving
[ __ ] boss so you got to be pretty
good with the camera you know lighting
uh how we get burned do they wrecked at
what else we get so did you guys hear
about this Chipotle incident no so a
video went viral of this
Chipotle worker asking for a customer to
pay before giving him his food and she
got fired over it because the video came
out and a lot of people were pointing at
the fact that the customer was black and
later it was revealed that they found
his Twitter account and he would tweet
things like dining and dashing is fun
and how he would like change up which
Chipotle he would dine in dasha as a
joke and so after that came out Chipotle
immediately apologized for firing the
Chipotle worker and rehired her jump to
these conclusions right assuming that
the person's racist I have the tweets
your honor the two with the tweets were
bad the tweet said that dude made way
way back Chipotle man good luck finding
better taco soft taco uther soft taco
light white rice chicken hot sauce a
little bit cheese I'm do it good luck
find better Mexico nothing wrong with
that [ __ ] you not fin I mean I like it I
don't really like you told us um I like
taco trucks 26th Avenue taco sounds
pretty good
I need to go to sidecar doughnuts today
and I'm gonna go get myself the goddamn
donut holes
no I'm does those cinnamon cinnamon
butter or whatever sugar the actual
doughnut yeah it's so good dude it's so
good no they've been around for a while
now oh my god I just had a thirsting for
it that's um dine and dash is forever
interesting all right let's move II said
just a bunch stuff like Chipotle's
catching up to us we got to go somewhere
else
he's probably they're dicks
soon I guarantee he's probably
originally from Somalia Somalia
alrighty not Ethiopian no because it's
in Minnesota so there's a large Somali
community there oh yeah
so an elevator in Chicago fell 84 floors
yeah this is not camera nobody died
everyone was fine there's a pregnant
the right item that elevator it thanks
it's ours Gary dude resume [ __ ] broke
off while they're heading down and then
I'm worse than have stamps back a safety
stop yeah there were other cables that
held it up just in time before it could
actually collapse all but two of the
cables just broke off how this is there
any video of them inside the elevator no
they couldn't they also couldn't get to
them without breaking through a brick
wall what to do if we get stuck I see
that they say not to open it up you know
a lot of people die because when you hit
the elevator you know a guy Jim good to
see ya
because you assume the elevators there
there's a ton of people that not want
ton but a lot of people die that way no
but it's not theirs do you like yeah
look it up it's science bro push door
open button no [ __ ] really cuz videos
gonna piss the main car being calm do
not try and pry up experts dr. no
colleagues lot [ __ ] no way this is it
relax not trying you're alright don't
man your dumb stuff what else you got so
do you guys know about the push of T
Drake beef sure do so last night he
performed at a Toronto State no arena
music hall Reiser call yeah dancer
Drake's from Toronto he's the face of
Tron but trying on the map running
through the six yeah I was part of the
Toronto Raptors designs their outfits
like he's a funny mister Toronto Darion
and Pusha T actually outed him for being
a dad recently he kept his son a secret
he had a fling with a porn star she she
was pregnant there are a bunch of rumors
that were released about it but he
always denied it and later on Pusha T
and Drake had some beef he wrote a song
called the story of Adonis saying that
he's a dad and he's a deadbeat because
he's gonna hide his son in a diss track
and a couple weeks ago at camp vlog now
push a tee were was performing and
somebody put up the screen
[ __ ] Dre
in the back while he's performing he
released a tweet and said that it was
actually because of like somebody within
like Klem flog nos I'd put that up like
some tech guy and he didn't approve it
there he was like if I was trying to
send shots I would have done it
differently
he's a very good lyrics it's a monster
lyrics that monster super monster mm-hmm
yesterday he performed in Toronto for
the first time since he had beef with
Drake and people try to run the stage
they waited for like him to perform a
specific song with a lyric that said
something along the lines of like wet or
getting soaked
they threw water and try to bum rush the
stage and they ended up getting jumped
it doesn't go well cuz push tea security
beats up all these guys including the
fans in the stadium they get [ __ ] up
but here's the thing this would be like
trying to [ __ ] like troll Michael
Jordan in Chicago like Jake's [ __ ]
Toronto man mm-hmm so watch this though
I don't think Drake hired these people
by the way
I think Barstow as the better video go
to barstool there's a reversal rush to
stay yeah watch this Barstow as the one
though because these guys get [ __ ]
there's a rumor circulating that Drake
bought the first like 200 tickets to the
show in order to get that done but I
don't think that's I don't think like
that waste his time with that he says
[Applause]
yeah okay konami god it's like a
flashlight
[Music]
they all get their athlete again stage
she just gets bucked and molly-whopped
[Music]
what do you think it's a bad idea real
[ __ ]
what complete [ __ ] play that one
there's the best thing of there we go
[ __ ] watch this though so they fill
that water I throwing water on the dude
alright cool
now rush the stage tell me how this goes
for you leave this just get like that
guys can stomp good now used to be one
of the security guys you know that fact
used to be that security guy for a corn
blink-182 hillary Dobb lurry Dobb gotta
have guys like you out there yeah but i
want to do that
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's not true what he's saying Drake
paid them to throw water Jake would've
paid these goons just for water no you
do it much more tackling smart fun beef
though I mean if you see if you've seen
the video of Drake and Chris Brown
getting a fight you'd know that you
wouldn't do [ __ ] like this silly it's
Zoey what else we got
um we got this one Rachel Austen [ __ ]
where we talked about this on below the
belt
dude show first of all do you know who
she is Brian the hottest fire C fighter
ever hotter than the ring cracker I
think other girls are hotter okay yeah
we but she's hot
yes carry on super dimepiece wait a
minute oh yeah so yesterday was thrown
off monday monday it turned out that she
was into some sort of a dispute and she
was assaulted and attacked it was a
domestic thing she broke her yeah so her
over to law was broken that's all we
knew and then turns out it was her
husband they got an argument something
happened he attacked her and now he's
going to jail for attempted murder
but she posted forgiving him being like
I know her brother said something like
she posted himself don't worry being
like you know everyone should be
forgiven they have their demons and all
this [ __ ] that's what a real victim [ __ ]
fake tits huh I mean damn 30 there's
some awesome titties I've got no time
for that it's not my thing and she was
supposed to fight Paige Vanzant in
January that's obviously off now tiny
then yeah she's very very tiny she's big
no she's small dimepiece fights off
husbands getting accused of murder so
poor hitting her in the face
you put her ass trying to kill it so oh
girl
you know where to find me if you need
help with your whatever no help for your
designing a shirt I'm just gonna help
with it come try out my chest if you
want to who else we got
so hopefully they give paid for she's
rush on it
that's a Russian name Hawaiian Austin
itch yeah I don't know her actual actual
background bush yes background with this
very skinny woman that is my friend Kyle
Kings wife a strong woman yep what does
she do though she she's a ring Carter
she a fight or two green card drunk
girl for a while I only choose anymore
shape I'm saying it's part team on it
okay what else you got you this one
there so what I'm not sure so this is a
little thing that someone put together
but if you did watch this press
conference between Tito Ortiz
he's a Chuck Liddell turn it up this is
him promoting Chuck Liddell and [ __ ]
to your team's fight which is Saturday
on pay-per-view now just watch this
that's cool in there she's this might be
right before they played it to edit it's
added a little bit I saw the but that's
it makes it look way worse but he didn't
he didn't pronounce Chuck Liddell's name
right still to this day they've talked
about it too and then the under cards he
goes in these guys all these fighters
here on the card to you just don't know
what he's doing
yeah he also does a mass amounts of
cocaine that's what it looks like to
pain from here via Tito's so you know
who your favorite fighters are the MMA
world I think about is Tito Ortiz and
Chuck Liddell
you know they've been they've been
staples for the longest time they've
been fighters who are who we've gone to
grow up with fighters with we've gotten
to know I mean there's fans out there
casual fans out there who can't name
anybody else but Tito Ortiz Enterprise
out is there we have we have an
excellent excellent this is my peer
party which which consists of 18 total
fights and I don't have a good memory to
to remember every single name but we we
have all the fighters here these guys
here and poor guy he's so high he's so
high so have it he's checked out English
is not his first language huh pretty
American
no he's deaf that he's born raising them
for you he speaks as though English is
his second no you don't know what he's
talking about
also he sounds like you know what sounds
like he in there maybe - mmm maybe I
just don't think you I think he does a
lot of drugs he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] he's got himself into and it's like
if you hired some random dude to pretend
he's your best friend at your funeral
and exactly uh you got these guy great
guys and it's gonna be fun all my grand
my grandfather when he died my father's
father we had there we had a priest and
the one thing that you couldn't say
about my father's father was that he
worked he didn't work he never worked he
had stopped working probably when he was
50 and even then he had kind of worked
at a brewery and hard work wasn't his
thing okay little lazy lazy being a dad
was easy Larry being a dad her husband
exactly wasn't exactly his thing calm
lazy Larry's doing anything wasn't
really his okay and when the priest got
up and said everyone knows you know Rick
Allen has an incredibly hard-working man
his whole life a great father and a
great husband is like oh man this
[ __ ] guy got hired no way no he
didn't do any research but well my
family's so funny cuz my family
everybody's like huh what's that yeah
including my dad come on my dad that's
what Oscars doing right now he's like uh
Chuck Liddell and you dork tease you
think when you think of MMA it's the
only - you think of [ __ ] man ten years
ago maybe yeah mmm you just done always
do I hope it again I'm gonna heal on two
back because I want Chuck and teedo get
paid but he was cold I think it I think
I think you get it
[ __ ] show of a production I have fun
Saturday I'm gonna watch it I'm sound
I'm gonna pay hard cold cash and watch
it yeah Brian's gonna legally stream it
not a big deal what else we got you just
a quick important message donating
lettuce oh yeah you type of lettuce
the CDC any land FDA no lettuce zero
they said don't risk it yeah did you not
see this I did try to get you know you
can't eat any lettuce what no letters I
mean listening no lettuce dude what if I
go to Chipotle absolutely not Wow hey
look at me I'm saying no lettuce why not
well God Jenna isn't ecoli break out God
we're dead even start Arizona but it
could be like it should be everywhere
kind of e.coli it's sort of a super bug
man body of shut ain't so much lateral I
do is he let us some a giant rabbit I
eat it from the field
Thanksgivings ruined there it goes
thanks stupid [ __ ] in the ecosystem
little poo gets on my Miley because Owen
[ __ ] and wipe their hands on lettuce
dammit
well is that it guys um if you want it
to be well not really a probably just
get everyone pissed off let me see I'm
gonna go do dips pull-ups and deadlift
I'm gonna get myself strong what else
you got
so I was showing you guys a little clip
of Ellen Pompeo so she went out and
during an interview she just said that
she wanted people around her like if
she's walking into a set she wants to
see people of color on a set like more
of their cool kids get on the next Black
Panther and shut the [ __ ] up I'll just
play on the movies is all the show
powers all trying to get to be part like
she disses virtue signaling exactly
it's her looking for attention yeah I
can't and everyone's applauding it to
just ask - Ellen Pompeo snapped and
there's a ton of women in the room but I
don't see enough color and I didn't see
enough color when I walked in the room
today and I had a meeting with a
director of another endorsement project
that I'm doing I said you know when I
show up on set I would like to see the
crew look like the world that I walk
around in every day
we're up to all productions to make sure
that your crew looks like the world we
see as Caucasian people it's our job
what do you mean a Caucasian people the
[ __ ] what do you mean by that about what
does that mean how do you I'm how I got
North African in me is that Caucasian or
Iberian what the [ __ ] I just did my Tia
genome
what do you mean cockades growing down
I'm so sick I was just applauding her
pretty much they were not even when I
watch it sounds like this is all about
prestige she just wants to be like where
were you saying this ten years ago why
is it cool why isn't the cool thing now
she's won attention now because all of
us are prejudiced you know why there are
a lot of like first of all I'm I said
there are a lot of different people of
color by the way but also like in in the
film business they're the best
hardest-working most competent people in
the world and nobody gives a [ __ ] what
you look like
can you do the job that's what people
are saying I don't give a [ __ ] listen
are to [ __ ] our best workers are both
Asian yeah I don't give a [ __ ] for years
we're black Asian why I just want the
best producer an intern we can get it's
like it's it's virtue signaling she's
looking prestige she wants status but I
wish my yes the new thing to do yes I do
I would trade Brian for a black with
your personality it's just hilarious I
will say this real quick though I went
to her Instagram to see if this is just
like a random thing to happen so she
does seem to be like about diversity I
know that and I'm not I'm not impressed
she doesn't she's not doesn't believe in
diversity or merit a meritocracy any
more than I do this is what Bob was
doing this let this felt so Union was it
next door I don't know this is just a
union Gabrielle Gabrielle what I say
Gabriel just so everybody knows you guys
just so you know she's setting an
example and she's not prejudiced thanks
Hollywood again thanks a lot for setting
such a great example of her saying I
should told the director I need to see
more that was just weird the director
went excuse me hey man you need to
see the best people for the job duly
noted the best people for the job agree
you know you could say the same thing
they used to say they said the biggest
thing was nobody ever wants to talk
about this their barracks Hollywood's
run by the Jews it's all Jews bla bla
bla this is what you'd hear and you know
so what about that the Jews have been
dealing with that forever you know so
you can always find any group now you're
dead with the gay mafia a lot of gays
and the it goes on and on when you start
breaking people down into groups it's
it's about who's best for the job
individuals treat people like
individuals and it goes back to that
every time and they miss this [ __ ] but
this is virtuous tickling this is just
feels it's now you get a lot of status
for finding racism everywhere and it
happens on college campuses happens with
dummies like that who really don't have
a lot of perspective she's a [ __ ]
actress I don't care I don't care you
know well said is that it that's it
thank you everybody she pisses off happy
[ __ ] thanks again I hope she [ __ ]
I hope you're not gonna be better not
beating white meat my dark me bit damn
right better I want to see my turkey
with some dark and white meat if I
walked in my house and there's only
white [ __ ] me hey I'll do you one
better if I walk into my house and I see
no people of color at my table even
though my family's white I don't have a
problem I'm never I wanna I want black
guys I want a ssin gals I want [ __ ] I
want all of it dude okay I want a Samoan
okay what about Mexicans bro can't have
that
what'd I say too much look I gotta draw
the line somewhere anyway I only ordered
dark meat round from that's why if you
know it's good comedy still the place
you can [ __ ] around a comic walk then
choking around there are black - there's
an Indian guy in a black comic - really
funny guys and we're all friends and the
comic walks in and goes oh I'm sorry
white this is so awkward this is a
whites-only area the black colleges he
gets everything ah sorry my bad I didn't
know that I go is that true that doesn't
even
it is I'm sorry I mean I agree with it I
don't think it's really bad but it was
so funny he was like I'm so sorry really
polite racist
well happy turkey day everybody happy
Thanksgiving be nice to each other we
are back next week
a few date for you guys next week's
become next week next Friday Saturday
I'm in New York City New York City at
Gotham comedy club Friday and Saturday
after that I'm in New Mexico right
outside Albuquerque December 7th and 8th
after that just announced I'm at the ice
house in Pasadena with some friends some
funny friends December 28th through the
29th two shows Friday to show Saturday
and then the granja go so San Diego
shoot my one hour Showtime special San
Diego June 19th
two shows one night those shows are
almost sold out Spreckels Theatre in San
Diego get your tickets now tief at
kake.com also the blackest Friday of all
time is happening on tea fat Kate calm
this Friday we just brought back the
freakin Scrooge McDuck our best selling
shirt of all time Abbot Kinney Fight
Club in military green we got the one
love Kalyn tease we have the street
fighter tease the store is restocked
with the biggest quantities we've ever
had and it's just for this Black Friday
the entire site is 25% off this Friday
after Thanksgiving code is T fat K 25%
off all merch all merch is stocked get
it now Friday
get up Friday Steve at kake.com New York
I will see you next week Friday Saturday
Ryan is at it that's hit party gobble
gobble gobble go on kid we're out